here is Oscar winner and denominator
Best Actress tonight Juliette Binoche mo
president of the Motion Picture
Association of America mr. Jack Valenti
cinema speaks to the world in every town
baby smiled in all men's tears and a
stolen kiss are universal they need no
translation five nominees for Best
Foreign Language Film truly illuminates
the diversity and ever-increasing
popularity of foreign films today and
the nominees are
from Mexico Morris Paris Alejandro
Gonzalez Inarritu from Taiwan Crouching
Tiger Hidden Dragon angly from the Czech
Republic divided before yon rebecc--
from Belgium
everybody famous Dominique they're
they're from France the taste of others
onion Joey and the Oscar goes Taiwan
for Taiwan
this is producer angley's first Oscar
for Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon
he also nominated in the Best Director
and Best Motion Picture categories
thank you oh well thank you Academy for
for this special recognition for long
English movies my thanks to my fellow
producers Chile Gong bill Kong and to
enormously talented cast and crew who
sacrificed so much to gem Sheamus devil
indeed title hope and everyone at a good
machine and to Barbara Robinson at
Columbia Asia and Garrett Wigan as Sony
and to Tom Boonen Michael Parker and
Marcy blue as Sony classic for their
masterpiece job and and finally to my
friends family in Taiwan to my
collaborators in Hong Kong and everyone
people in China who helped us so much in
making this movie it's a great honour
thank you